I think we're at the cost of using AI
for probably the biggest trans-positive
transformation that education has ever
seen and the way we're going to do that
is by giving every student on the planet
an artificially intelligent but amazing
personal tutor it can answer questions
it can quiz you it can connect it to
other ideas and it's not just exercises
it understands what you're watching it
understands the context of your video it
can answer the age-old question why do I
need to learn this and it asks
socratically well what do you care about
and let's say the student says I want to
be a professional athlete and it says
well learning about the size of cells
which is what this video is on that
could be really useful for Understanding
Nutrition and how your body works Etc
that could take your average student and
turn them into an exceptional student it
can take your below average student and
turn them into an above average student